it's a denim Delight for Prince William
and Kate Middleton's 2022 Christmas card
so Christmas is always a really special
time for the royal family and where they
do traditionally come together and that
has always been at Sandringham and my
understanding is that King Charles III
is going to follow his mother's
tradition and host a family Christmas at
Sandringham this year on Tuesday the
prince and princess of Wales shared a
new family photo that doubles as their
Christmas card there's Kate and William
strolling through a garden alongside
their three kiddos Prince George
princess Charlotte and Prince Louis the
theme denim a much more relaxed look for
the fam who we usually see in formal
attire the sweet portrait was captured
earlier this year at their home in
Norfolk England and while will Kate and
the kids are no doubt looking forward to
the holidays it seems they'll be
celebrating apart from some family
members Harry and Megan have been
invited for Christmas but it's our
understanding that they won't be coming
over to the UK they will be spending the
holiday season in California the royal
family photo was released nearly a week
after part one of Harry and Megan's
documentary dropped on Netflix in the
dock Megan recalls her first kinda
awkward meeting with her brother and
sister-in-law and they came up for
dinner I remember I was in ripped jeans
and I was barefoot
[Music]
it's like I was a hugger I've always
been a hugger I didn't realize that that
is really a
jarring for a lot of prints
I guess I'd start to understand very
quickly that the formality on the
outside carried through on the inside
[Music]
that there is a forward-facing way of
being
and then you close the door and you oh
great
you can relax now
but that formality carries over on both
sides
and that was surprising to me I think
our suspicions about this being a pretty
cool relationship right from the start
have have been confirmed here and I
think it also
confirms what we've always known which
is that Megan and Kate are two very very
different women you know that's why they
were never going to be best friends as
for the brothers Harry and William are
still at odds their relationship became
strained in 2020 after Harry decided to
step back from his senior Royal duties
and it seems their Rift might only grow
wider once part two is released on
December 15th to see this institutional
gas lighting I wasn't being thrown to
the Wolves I was being fed to the Wolves
they were actively recruiting people to
disseminate disinformation
they're happy to lie to protect my
brother they were never willing to tell
the truth to protect us you do you think
that their brothers will ever come
together will the king ever accept Harry
back can this family this fractured
family be fixed I was told there are
always open arms from this side of the
Atlantic it's just they received more
coldly on the other side of the pond I
think if Harry and Megan are going to
continue to tarnish some might even say
trash the reputation of the monarchy and
let's not forget the timing of this it
comes at the start of the king's Reign
at the time when he's putting down the
blueprint for his Reign on the eve of
his coronation for the media to be
dominated by the alternative Royal Court
in California that's a problem for the
monarchy
[Music]